Aが生まれる時 Bが生まれる
という現れの現れ方 なに
これダブってるんではないかと考えられるかもしれませんね A
があるときBがありますって言ったらそれで終わりますよと
でもちょっとすごく複雑に考えてるんですね
お釈迦様は だから二行にしているんですね
一番目は あの Aがある時なんですね A
がある時Bが Bもありますと
だからいつでもBのことをAが支えてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
ずっと  二番目はイマスウッパーダーというのはもうAが生まれるんですね
いわゆるAがなかったんですね
で なかったAという原因条件がもう現れてくると B
というものも見えてきます
だから一行目はAがあるときBがあるという言葉で言うと
やっぱり一般的な条件
世の中のことを見る場合の見方と
二番目っていうのは新しく現象が出てくる場合は
その新しく現れてくる現象について因縁に基づいて見る場合ですね
その二つもやっぱり必要なんです
なぜならば 今の世の中を説明するためには因縁論を使いましょうと言っても
今の世の中そのままずっとあるわけじゃないんですね
今の世の中って世の中はずっと変化していくんですね
違う状況に変わっていっちゃうんですね
やっぱりそちらにも因果論を当てはめなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 世の中の現象の二つの側面がある
まず現象を説明することと
その現象が変えて違う現象になるんですね
その変えて変えて違う現象になることも説明しなくちゃいけないんですね
その両方まとめるために
そのダブっているように
みんなまあどうせパーリ語っていうのは同じことを繰り返し繰り返しだからつまらないと文句言いながら読んでいるんだからね
やっぱり あの そこら辺では厳密に考えてるんですね
そこでこの二行目 二番目のセット
三行目と四行目はその反対なんですね
イマスミンアサティイダンナホーティ
これがない時はこれもないと
一番目の意味 これがない時
これもないと これは現代風に言えばAがない時 B
もないと AがなければBもありませんとという否定の言葉で
四行目はイマスニローダ
これが滅する時はこれも滅すると
いわゆるAが消えてしまえばBも消えてしまうと
で ここでも あの これこの方程式ですけどね
ですからこの数字で書けばAがあるときBがある A
が生まれるときBが生まれる A
がないときBがない A
が消えるときBも消えるという四行目にしなくちゃいけないんです
この方程式自体理解すれば
まあそれで結構立派だと思いますけどね
で 今日これを説明しますのは
このアビダンマではこれあまり使ってないんです
そこでこのない時ない
消える時は消えちゃったという二つ目のセットで何を説明していますかというと
一般的に文字だけ 字だけ読むと
繰り返してるんではないかと
同じこと AがあるときBがあるという場合は A
がないときBがないというのは当たり前ではないかと
まあダサいことと思っちゃうんですね
でも 方程式を喋る場合は
そんなこの普通に喋る場合みたいに余計な言葉まで言ったらあかんでしょうし
ですから やっぱりすごく厳密に考えて
そこら辺をお釈迦様おっしゃってて
経典の中でもお釈迦様それで喋る時はすごくあの自分がどのように物事をこの修行中で考えた時はこれを発見しました
これつもちゃんと並んでいっちゃうんですね
それで番目のセットで世の中の変化を説明しているでしょうに
なぜ世の中は変化しているんですかと
なぜ一定していないんですかと
世の中は現れることを説明したならば
現れた世の中はずっとその通りにいなくちゃいけないでしょうに
でも世の中っていうのはあるんだけど
その通りにいるわけじゃないんですね
すると消えて変化していっちゃいますから
この変化の過程もやっぱり見なくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 番目も必要になっちゃうんですね
そこで番目のセットでは現れる過程
どのように現れる 現れる過程はつあります
常に世の中一般的にあることと新しいものが生まれてくることですね
番目は消える過程 今ある世界が消えていく
その過程そこで説明しなくちゃいかん
そこでまたそれでもセットつになってしまうんちゃう
それは一つの意味なんですね
世の中の生まれることと世の中の消えることは理解しなくちゃいけない
それでもう一つ問題があるんですね
で 自分が使った原因 発見した原因が確かにそうかないかと
その疑いがあるんですね
人間というのはものすごい大雑把で勝手に原因は言います
まあいつでも私は幽霊なんですけど
神様が原因で人間がいるんだと
いわゆる神様に創造されて人間がいるんだと
本当にそうですかという
やっぱりことも考えなくちゃいけないんですね
そう考えてバチが当たるんだからやめなさいと言っちゃうんですね
そういうのは知識人の世界ではないんですね
それは無知な人にはそれで構いませんだけど
仏教は知識の世界だから
それは認めません 罰が当たるという概念は認めません
たとえ罰が当たっても
たとえ文化で認めてあっても
たとえ年の歴史の中で信じてきたっても
そんな構いません もう全部分析して考え直したりしたりする
そういう人間の無意味な感情はもう使わないんだから
使わない世界だから ですから
やっぱり本当に自分考えた原因が本当にそれは原因か
違うものもないかという疑いがいつでもあります
そこでしっかり原因をつかめなくちゃいけないんですね
いえ これは原因だと そうでないと問題ですからね
おそらくこうだろう おそらくこうだろうというのは
もう原因はわかってない状態です
そういうおそらくこうだろうではなくて
原因はこういう原因ですよと言うために言わなくちゃいけない
それはどのように作ります
作りますかというと イマスメンサティダンゴーティ
がある時これがありますと A
がある時Bがありますよというならば A
がない時Bがないと その反対も必要なんですね
だからAがない場合はBがないと
何かAがある場合はもういつでもBがいるんだ A
がないとBもないと それだったらBの原因はAでありますよということは確実なんですね
ですから Aが生まれる時 B
も生まれてしまうならば A
が消えちゃったら 死んじゃったらBも同時に消えて死んでしまうちゃう
それだったらしっかりした原因なんですね
もう疑いはなし ぴったしと原因と結果になってしまいます
で そういう風に語らなくちゃいけないんですね
原因結果は だから難しいんです
で 例で考えてみましょう
で 車の鍵を入れて鍵を回さないとスタートはしませんと
それは まあそれは原因だよと
車をスタートするためには鍵を回すと
それで鍵回さなかったら車はスタートしませんと
ああ わかったと それで車をスタートする場合は
本当に鍵回すことは原因ですかね
それでもし他の人があのダッシュボードを外して
あの あの電源のワイヤーありますから
それ繋げておけばカチンとスタートするんですね
何のことなく それでほら
鍵を回さなくても車がスタートするということになっちゃうんですね
ですから 鍵を回すことで車がスタートするということは
本物の原因でなくなっちゃうでしょうに
それでやっぱりモーターにこのスターターモーターですから
そのモーターに電気をあげないと車がスタートしないということになります
だから電気があると車がスタートするんですね
電気がないと車はスタートしない
それだけだから鍵の関係は消えてしまっちゃうんですね
ボネットを開けてでも直接モーターに電気を入れてあげればもうスタートしますから
エンジンはかかります
それで じゃあ原因見つかったんですか？車のエンジンかかる原因が
そこでこのスターターモーターなんかなくたっても車はスタートできますよ
エンジン 必ずしももう電気バッテリーがあって
そういう必要でもないんですね
まあバッテリーは まあガソリンだったら燃やすために必要ですから
まあしょうがないんだけど
モーターがなくてもちょっと工夫してスタートすることはできるし
だからそういうわけで
この厳密になぜ車がスタートするかっていう厳密な原因を探すっていうことはかなりややこしくなる
ただそれだけ言いたかったんです
モーターが動かなくたっても
車を押してもらって 電気だけこの
あの あの 何て言いますか
あのスパークプラグというやつがあってね
そちらに電気だけつなげてるんだったら
エンジンがかかりますから
なんとかしてあのガソリンを燃やしてもらえば大丈夫です
ですから このしっかりしたAがある時 B
があるという風にしっかりと世の中のものの原因見つかるっていうことは
なかなか複雑で難しい
だから因果法則のその立場を理解してほしいんです
そんなに簡単じゃないと
で そこはこの具体的に我々の日常生活の中で
我々はこのそこら辺間違っちゃうとこありますから
まあまあこの我問的な世界ではなくて
我々の日常の生活の中でも
やっぱりあの すぐ決めつけて
これだからこうなったんですよと
決めつけて行動したりするんですね
それで我々の人生の中でも
もうかなりトラブルを起こしちゃうんですね
あなたはこうしたんだからこうなったよと
もう決めたと という感じで決めつけちゃうんですね
本当にそうかと 逆をあなたはこうしなかったら
こういう結果にならないかと
それも考えなくちゃいけない
日常生活で 例えば旦那さんが毎日遅くなってくるんだと
それで奥さんがヒステリー起こったりして
もう家庭はバラバラになってしまったと
で 奥さんが文句を言う
あなたのせいだと で 決めつけて
もう家庭はバラバラになっちゃうでしょうに
じゃあ逆を考え じゃあということは
旦那さんが遅く帰るという原因でしょうに
その原因消えた場合は遅くして帰らない
或いは早く帰る それで家庭は平和でということはありますか？という
そのしっかりした証拠はあるかと
それもないんですね だからそこら辺は我々はやっぱり原因の世界だから
これそんな簡単にわかるわけじゃないと理解して落ち着かなくちゃいけないので
決めつけてはいけないんですね
物事は 決めつけるところ
決めつけたところで そこは間違っているんですね
だからしっかりした原因見つかればよろしいんだけど
見つかりますか？ということなんですね
あまりにもありすぎて
でも論理的に語る場合は A
があるからAがある時Bがありますよという場合は
やっぱりAがない場合は本当にBもないと
それだったらABの原因はAになるんですね
それぐらいしっかりとつかまなくちゃいけない
そういうわけで お釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
因縁っていうのはそういう風にしっかりつかまったもので
これしっかりつかまれないものについては語ってないんです
他の人が考えるとするならば
これを考えたとしてもそれは構いませんし
で 因果論こそがもう正しい人間の考え方なんですね
因果論には別に信仰は要りませんし
で しっかり考える 物事考える
研究する 実験するということだけあればよろしいし
だから仏教の科学性というかね
科学的であるところはまあこちらにぎっしりついているんですね
仏説とは何ものかといえば
すべて因果論なんです
[背景の音楽]因果論も捨てたらそれで仏教はなくなっちゃうんです
他の何も喋ってないんです
この四つの方程式に基づいて
お釈迦様はこの十二因縁の話をしているんです
だから十二因縁はしっかりしている教えなんです
そこからまたもう考えなくちゃいけない問題いっぱいありますけど
この特にこのナガールジュナさんがこの龍樹という人がこの方程式を否定するんですね
ですから この本当は別に否定する
これは間違ってるということを言ってるわけじゃなくて
まあ人間のね 取り方間違ってるんだっていうことで
で これ否定することで認めようとという努力ですけどね
で 彼は彼なりにしっかり喋ってますけど
やっぱり彼にもちょっとしたこの立場
土台があって 実体論という
このセスサユブとヒンドゥー教で徹底的に実体があるという概念を持っていたんですね
そこで言葉もね 言語論もなんかちょっとややこしくなりまして
で そういう考え方 背景にあって
彼がこういうものを否定しちゃうんですね
言語論からそれ見るとわかりやすいんですけど
例えばバラの花といった言葉がありますね
なぜバラの花という言葉があるかというと
バラの花という実体があるんだからなんです
そうでないとバラの花という言葉は成り立ちませんね
人間コミュニケーションもできなくなっちゃうんですね
じゃあ五時に駅で会いましょうというと
五時に実体がなければ
駅に実体がなければ 会うということがなければ
どうやって成り立つんですかね
で 聞いた人はそれを理解するんですね
私はじゃあ五時に駅で会いましょうと言ったら
聞いた側が何か理解するんですね
理解して ぴったし二人が五時に駅で会っちゃうんですね
だからやっぱり言葉には実体がなければいけませんというふうに
この言語的言語論を考えた人々はいたんですけどね
で それとお釈迦様の言語論は随分違いますけど
それはまあセスサユブとヒンドゥー世界で実体論を語っていて
その世界の実体論なんですね
椅子といえば椅子 何かなければ言葉意味がないんですね
だから椅子 椅子という言葉と椅子
実体というのはもうもう離れません
言葉と実体に関係なければ
もう喋らないしね 私はご飯食べる時に私は椅子を食べてますよと言えますから
それで構いません だから関係なければ
でもご飯食べる場合はご飯食べてますよとしか言えませんね
椅子を食べてますよと言っちゃったら間違ってるんですね
というわけで 言葉には厳密に意味があって
働きがあって 実体があるということになってしまいます
龍樹はただそれだけ否定しているんですね
だから まあそんなに言葉に実体があるんだと思ってない場合は
言葉っていうのは まあ初期仏教だったら
人間の認識の世界で経験というものがあって
その経験を表現するために
自分の自分のために表現するときも
他人のために表現するときでも
何かをラベリングするんですね
それだけ ですね ラベリングに確実にピッタシ合う経験やら実態はあってもなくても構いませんし
このラベリングは同じラベリングだったら言語というもの成り立つし
コミュニケーションが成り立ちます
で 我々は椅子というし
もう英語を喋る人々はチェアというし
ラベリングが違うんですね
それでコミュニケーションできなくなっちゃうんです
だからもう人間勝手にラベリングするだけのことで
向こうはチェアとラベリングするし
こちらでは椅子とラベリングするし
それでコミュニケーションできるというのは
チェアという音も椅子ということばも全くまあただの言葉ですよと
同じものを同じ経験を意味していますよと分かったところでコミュニケーションできます
そういうわけで 言葉っていうのは単なる道具にしか何もないんですね
だからこのヴィパッサナー瞑想でもラベリングする仕事をよくやってますけどね
そちらにもそれなりのすごく深い意味があるんです
そこをやったところで
この無明の壁が破れるはずなんです
言葉に引っかかって 言葉によって感情的になって
世の中をむちゃくちゃにしているんだからね
何もわからなくなってるんだから
それだったらラベリングしてみなさいと
その瞬間瞬間の経験を
いうわけでね まあヴィパッサナー瞑想なんか単純でバカバカらしいやとと思っても
で かなり厳密にこの教えに基づいて
やってるも大変な仕事なんです
で 人間というのは言葉のその働きが知らなくて
自由に言葉を使っちゃうんですね
だから自由に言葉を使うところで
この妄想の世界が生まれてきて
結果この宗教の神様も現れてきちゃうんですね
だからラベリングしちゃったら神様が現れないはずなんですね
だからいるかいないかということは
もう非論理的な考え方で
これ証明できませんから
いるとも証明できないし
いないとも証明できないし
ですから このもう勝手にこの正しくラベリングしない
それで ああ素晴らしいと
とにかくまあゾッな感じになっちゃうと
やっぱりそういう神様も魂もなんだかんだ言っても現れてきますね
ほとんど幻想ですね だから真理知るためには
やっぱり左足上げます
下げます 上げます っていいんです
その人のは智慧が発達していきます
何も聖なるものはそこにない
具体的に自分には左足といったら何かあるし
上げると言ったら何か感覚があるし
下ろすといえば何か感覚があるし
下ろすというのは何か感覚があるし
だから解釈を抜きにする
解釈っていうのは経験に過ぎてのものだから
もう実際性というかね
それ消えちゃうんですね
だから解釈はしない 解釈すると
もう事実からもうかけ離れているんですね
まあで それからまたナガラジュナの話に戻りますけど
だからナガラジュナはこのAがある時 B
がありますよというと A
があるんだから それまたBもあるんだから
で なんでBの原因Aだと言えますかと
言えないんだと そこでAもあってBもあると A
があるときBがあるという場合はね
ということは原因もあって結果もあるんだと
ということは これ原因結果じゃないんだと二人でもいるんだから A
もいてBもいるんだから
なんでAからBが生まれると言えます？言えませんと
だからそんなこと間違ってると
例で見れば種もあって芽もあるんだと
種もあって木があるんだと
それだったらもう木があるはもう実が出るは
やっぱり元の種もそのまんまであるということになっちゃうんですね
そんなことはあり得ませんだからね
成り立ちませんと 故にAがあるときBがあるっていうことは成り立ちませんと
そういう感じでずっと否定していくんですね
またいろいろいろんな方角で彼が説明していますけど
でも彼の立場がAという実体がある B
という実体があるということなんです
お釈迦様の因果論というのは実体論ではないんだから
なんとも言えないんですね
本当に見てみると だから車があるといえば車がありますけど
やっぱりそれぞれの部品がなければ車は成り立ちませんし
車があると言ったらエンジンもあるし
車体もあるし サセキサセキもあるし
もう全部あるんですね
だからそういうものあるならば車があるということで
車という別個の実体と思っちゃったら
それは因果法則でなくなっちゃうんですね
それは龍樹さんが否定しているんですね
いや とにかく難しくなりますから
そこら辺でやめます それぐらいはお釈迦様の因果法則で
しっかりと原因と結果は見つからなくちゃいけない
だからって仏教実体のことはあると言っているわけじゃないんです
もう一つ言いたいのは
世の中の私たちがこの仏教で
特にアビダンマ的に分析すると
まあ嫌だと そんなことはもうなんでそんな木目細かく分析するんだと
まあやっぱりそれは真理じゃないと思ったりする
合成してね 合成論はまあ立派だ
そんな分離できませんと
人間というのは心も体もそんなもう一体であって分離できませんとかね
そういう風に無責任の無知な話は言いますけど
じゃああんた方は合成論知ってますかと
ところで これは理解もできないでしょう
結局合成論も知らないで嘘ばっか知ってるんですね
合成論自体も分析論と同じく
もうかなり厳密なんです
うん じゃあこれからこの十二因縁の話に行きます
番目はアヴィッジャ アヴィッジャ
パッチア サンカーラですね
アヴィッジャは言葉知ってますし
皆様方 無明によって パッチアっていうのは
よってサンカーラ 行が生まれると
だからあの あの四つの方程式に合わせてみたっても
アヴィッジャがある時はサンカーラがありますと
アヴィッジャがない時はサンカーラもなくなっちゃうし
アヴィッジャが生まれるともうサンカーラももう生まれている
アヴィッジャが消えちゃうとサンカーラも一緒にいっぺんに消えてしまう
ですから アヴィッジャとサンカーラの関係はもう厳密にしっかりしている
無明と行の関係 我々の世界で私たちが考えているような大雑把な因果関係ではないんです
だからそこで問題はアヴィッジャという項目は何を意味するかと
サンカーラというような項目自体は何を意味するかというところでは
また分析論が必要なんですね
そのためにずっと分析してきたんです
だから本当はこの因果
このページに入って この章に入っちゃったらさっと言って終わっちゃうんです
難しいんだけど すごい時間全然時間かからない
もうとっくに皆様方はアヴィッジャというのはこういうものだと明確に知っておかなくちゃいけないので
これまた説明するようになっちゃうと
また私は分析論に戻るようになってきちゃってます
まだずっとアビダンマ
またもう初めから語らなくちゃいけない
それでやりきれなくなっちゃうんですね
それでまた無明から行が生じていたところで無明はわからないという
アヴィッジャっていうのは無明であって無知であって
このモハですね この心素の中でモハという心素なんですね
で でもあの そういうものなんですけど
本当は毛髪だけではなくて
そういうお釈迦様の立場ではいえば
どんな行も無明から生じますということで
確実に無知そのものでなくてもいいみたいですね
ですから 経典で無明の説明っていうのは知らないこと
真理 知らないこと 無能ですと
真理は姿勢体ですからね
空住滅度ですからね 存在は空住滅度であることはまだ知らない
だからもう基本的な条件ですね
人間のアヴィッジャーっていうのは
で 空住滅度を理解するためにはすごい苦労して
頭を磨いて修行して やがてわかるものであって
何かわかるということは大変な努力の結果なんですね
何もしないんだから 全てわかっているよっていうのはありえないことなんですね
だから 世の中の常識と同じく
何か知りたければ その分は努力しなくちゃいけない
知識が欲しいであるならば
勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
私は勉強していないんだから
全ての知識持ってますよというのはもう成り立たない話なんですね
ですから 姿勢体を理解することにしたっても
それなりの努力は必要ですし
努力していない場合は無明と言うんですね
ですから この一般的な心の状況なんですね
アヴィッジャーっていうのは
そこで知らない人は何を知ってますかというと
やっぱりいろんな行動をしなくちゃいけないんですね
行動はミスでしょうし
考えること 喋ることと体を動かすことですね
身口意の行動をしなくちゃいかない
考えるか喋るか体を動かすこと
ですから心の働きなんですね
だから知らない人がどうせ働くでしょうし
そのことに向かって自分が英語を知らないと
英語は全く知らないんだと思ってしまえば
その思う瞬間でなぜ思うかというと
英語を知る必要がありますよという時なんですね
英語を知る必要はありませんよと
まるっきり知らないうちは気がつかないんです
そこである人 やっぱり英語を知っておかなくちゃいけないということに気がつく
無明に気がつく 無明に気が付いちゃったら
じゃあ英語を知ってやろうではないかと思って行動するでしょうね
それからその人が考える
喋る 行動するということになりますね
だから英語を勉強するという行動が
行為が 英語を知らないという無明でなければ成り立ちませんでしょ
英語を知らない それは無明イコール無明
そうすると英語を勉強する
それはサンカーラ 行 それである人はもう生まれつき英語を知っていると
そうすると その人は英語を勉強するということは要らなくなっちゃうんでしょうね
だから無明がなければ行が生じません
例えば我々は違う国に生まれたんだから
違う言語を喋るんだから英語は知りません
英語の圏に生まれた子供っていうのは
知っている言葉は英語でしょうね
英語を知っている それは私たちはもう歳に歳になっても英語を勉強したいなと思っているし
向こうはそんなに思ってないんですね
だからそこでこの無明と行の関係をね
方程式に合わせて考えてみてください
英語は知らないことに気が付いたと
無知に気が付いたと 英語を知らないという条件がある
原因がある それでサンカーラが生まれると
英語を勉強すると そういうことで行動
身口意 頭で考える 心で頭で考える
言葉喋る 体で行動する
その一切の行動の原因は無明であるというすごい巨大な教えなんです
それは究極的な真理なんです
だから英語を知らない
だから英語を勉強するっていうふうな
もう単純な もうくだらない話じゃないんです
これが